PROFESSOR: Hello.
I'm Ian Hutchinson, and the
purpose of this short video
is to give you illustration
of how to use Octave.
I'm certainly not an
expert at [? Octave, ?]
which is an open source
equivalent of MATLAB,
but that's part of
the demonstration.
Here's someone who's
not an expert who
can use this routine
for carrying out
the kinds of exercises
that we want to do.
So I'm going to delete my
picture from the screen
now, and just show you
the rest of the screen.
Here I am in a directory.
I'm going to start a new file.
It's going to be called fitting.
Let's say, fitting.m,
is the correct extension
for a MATLAB or Octave file.
And I've opened Emax, and
I'm ready to get started.
Actually, I'm going to
run Octave simultaneously
in the adjacent window.
I run Octave here.
So now I'm in a situation
where I, essentially,
have my own IDE, integrated
development environment.
It's not quite the
same as you would
have if you're
running MATLAB itself,
but it's pretty similar.
What I'm going to do now is
develop this fitting program.
I'm going to start
with some parameters.
Let's, first of all,
define the number
of points I'm going to fit.
Let's make it a small number,
so that it's kind of manageable.
And now, let's generate
some x and y values.
I can set x to be
equal to an array.
It might be an array
with six points.
And I'm going to make it
be run from 1 to endpoints.
And so I do that by saying
x is equal to 1 colon
endpoints like this.
I can save this file--
it's called fitting--
and then I can run it in
Octave by just typing fitting.
If I do that, what
you see happens is,
it tells me that endpoints is 6.
Tells me that x is
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and 6.
Actually, I don't want
it to run from 1 to 6.
I want it to run
from, essentially,
a small value up to 1.
So let's divide
it by end points.
And I can save that file
again, run it again,
and now, of course,
my screen shows
that it runs from 1/6 up to 1.
This is, of course,
a row vector.
It's preferable that I
have a column vector.
I can transform a row
vector into a column vector
by taking its transpose.
In MATLAB or Octave,
transpose is prime.
So I can say,
transpose the numbers 1
through 6 into a column vector
and then divide by endpoints.
And if I do that
and save the file,
then I see I've turned
it into a column vector.
Let me now make a y variable.
y, I'm going to make
equal to x, let's say.
That would just give
me a straight line,
if I made it nothing but x.
Then I'll add to it
some small fraction--
let's say, 1/10th-- not 0.1
times the sine of, let us say,
10 x.
I can save that file.
I can run it again.
And it tells me,
here's x and here's y.
That's given me a start.
Actually, it's a
bit inconvenient
to see it in quite those terms.
So let's actually
try to plot it.
So I can say plot x y.
Save that and run it.
And lo and behold,
it brings up a plot.
The labeling is
rather too small,
but that's kind of built
into the rather poor graphics
in Octave and MATLAB,
for that matter.
That can be fixed in ways
that I'll go into later,
but we won't worry about it now.
This is a line plot, which
is a little bit annoying.
So let's change that plot.
I'll put the figure over here.
I'll change that
plot by telling it
that it's going to have
points, and those points
are going to have the
form of a plus sign.
So let's save that
and run it again.
And Lo and behold, it's changed
it to a plot with points.
Again, the markers are
rather unpleasantly small.
I can actually change that
if I want by telling it
a string marker size.
Making that size larger than
it would be-- let's say, 20--
and running it again.
And lo and behold,
the points are bigger.
So we've started, and
we've made, some data.
And we've used parameters.
And in our next
video, we'll move on
to finding out how to
proceed on that basis.